if you see a man dressed up as a woman  and they're like close to you it's scary  it's objectively scary because it's also  like i don't know how stable this person  is they're a lot bigger than me i'm not  allowed to say anything about it or act  like something's off it's scary and i  think that is a reasonable reaction to  that kind of thing i i want people to to  stop thinking they're not allowed to say  anything i understand why people do  think we're not allowed to say anything  there's a tremendous amount of social  pressure to go along with this and to  not be mean and to be nice to the man  and the pink dress i know i get it but i  really think that even though it is  republicans in the political arena who  are standing up against this americans  across the political spectrum could kill  this if we would get together and start  talking about it i really think we could